Du tar resurser från jorden och skapar en produkt.
Finns det inga regler för vem som får göra det?
Vill vi skapa en värld som är lite bättre om några år, så behöver vi kanske fundera på vilka produkter verkligen som behövs på marknaden.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men...
Alltså man tar det positivt.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Maria Siraki till podden och jag har försökt få med Maria här i...
Jag har säkert jagat dig ett halvår för att få med dig här i podden och skrivit någon gång i månaden.
Är det dags nu?
Kan du vara med nu?
Och nu sitter du här.
Välkommen till podden.
Tack Joel, så himla kul att vara här.
Jättegottroligt.
Men nu är detta ju nästan...
Det är nästan bättre att bara skicka över folk till din egna podd istället.
Du har ju en egen podd nu.
Ja men precis.
Vi startade för några månader sedan, några veckor sedan.
Tre avsnitt har vi lanserat än så länge.
Vad är det för podd?
Den heter Rebel Up eller något sådant?
Ja, den heter Rebel Up.
Det handlar om mig och Louise Lennarsten, en tjej här från Linköping, Östergötland, som också är entreprenör och vi delar med oss av våra liv som entreprenörer, som mammor, som vårt liv egentligen, och vill att fler ska våga ta en annan väg än den här breda motorvägen som man lätt kan hamna i.
Ja, det är vad det handlar om.
Varför vill ni att folk inte ska bara köra på det beprövad?
Finns det inte en charm i svensksomlivet?
Klart det finns.
Men jag tänker att det finns så himla många som tänker att man ska göra på ett annat sätt eller leva på ett annat sätt.
Och så vågar man inte för att man är så himla rädd vad alla andra ska tycka.
Jag tror många tänker såhär, vad ska den och den och den och den och den personen tycka och tänka?
Det är ingen som bryr sig om vad du gör egentligen.
Så bara kör, gör din grej.
Även om det är lite konstigt.
Känner du igen det där för att du själv har varit sån eller är det......garanterat?
Både och skulle jag säga i perioder.
Vissa perioder har jag börjat köpa på.
Andra perioder har jag liksom så här...
Det är därför jag krisat och insett så här men gud, varför har jag tagit den här vägen?
Det var väldigt lätt att ta den vägen.
Det var lätt att börja jobba på bank efter mina studier fast jag egentligen inte ville det.
Rent ekonomiskt var det positivt men rent själsligt så var det inte det.
Så fastnade jag där i sju år.
Det är ganska lång tid.
Så ja, jag har både fastnat i den här breda vägen men också uppfattat det och förstått det.
Och sen bara nej, men jag ska ju hitåt egentligen.
Så ja, det är väldigt mycket egen erfarenhet med att man ska vakna upp och gå sin egna väg.
Och den kan vara att man kör medströmmen, definitivt, bara om man är medveten om det, tänker jag.
Vad är det som får en människa att nu ska jag fan ta tag i detta eller nu ska jag göra?
Är det att man lyssnar på en podd och så säger folk, nu får du fan skärpa dig, skit i detta nu.
Verkligen inte.
Hur valde du själv att bara gå, ja men, ta tag i det eller vad man ska säga.
Jag har nog krisat när det har gjort ont och när jag har känt att jag inte är lycklig och försökt förstå mig själv och vem jag är som person och varför är jag inte lycklig i grunden just nu.
Vad är det jag gör i min vardag?
Och sen kanske jag lyssnar på en podd och sen kanske jag hör någon låt och så kanske jag pratar med en vän och så kanske jag pratar med en psykolog, vem vet.
Och sen så kanske det händer någonting.
Det kanske är på ett jobb och så ska de se upp massor av människor.
Och du kanske är en av dem.
Då blir det som en knuff åt en annan riktning.
Så när en podd, förresten din podd, inspirerar mig väldigt mycket också.
Men jag tror inte bara, jag tror att det är en sammantagen grej som gör att man kanske gör en förändring.
Att det är många saker i sitt liv som man vill förändra och så gör man det.
För att det kanske gör för ont att fortsätta på det sättet man redan gör.
Rätta mig om jag är fel, men jag för mig att jag...
Var inte du med i någon podd och pratade om...
Vad är detta?
Pratade inte du om att du hade liksom byggt det livet du ville ha, eller du hade byggt det företaget du ville ha, eller...
Nej, jag hade byggt ett liv som var väldigt fyrkantigt.
Jag är en väldigt kreativ person egentligen, men jag har hört hela livet att det är bara en hobbygrej egentligen.
Att hålla på att vara designare eller fotograf eller vara en konstnär, det är ju inte någonting du kan tjäna pengar på och leva på.
Så det har varit i min bakhuvud hela tiden, men jag måste ha ett riktigt jobb.
Jag behöver jobba någonstans där jag kan få en lön och sedan bygga upp mitt liv därifrån.
Så jag har ju alltid nekat mig själv att göra saker som jag vill för att jag har haft en inställning, att jag har fått höra det.
Mina föräldrar som kommer från Grekland, arbetarklass, de tycker ju det här med konst och formgivning, vad man gör där, det är en rolig grej men skaffa ett riktigt jobb sedan.
Och dessan är ju kvar liksom mig själv.
Så jag hade byggt det här livet, jobbade på bank som sagt, och var i en relation som jag inte trivdes i, jag hade kompisar jag inte trivdes med heller.
Många saker i mitt liv som jag kände varför gör jag det här.
Och sen sakta men säkert så började det ändra på saker och ting.
Det var då jag var 40.
Och det var också då jag startade NVH, bara av en slump egentligen.
Exakt, vad var det första du tog tag i?
Var det relationen som var det första, eller var det vänner eller någon vän som var det första, eller var det företag?
Vad var första steget mot the new and improved Maria?
Maria.
Alltså det första var ju, det låter väldigt enkelt, men år innan min förstårskris så hade jag börjat jobba med mig själv, med personlig utveckling och försöka förstå mig själv.
Men då när jag fyllde 39-40 där så bytte jag jobb.
Jag jobbade på arbetsmedlingen med ett projekt som var med kvinnor som hade kort utbildning och var utländsk förda.
Så jag coachade dem i tidiga veckor, i grupp efter grupp.
Och så sade de upp massor med människor och då tänkte jag så här, men nu är det dags för mig att göra något annat, någonting som jag tycker är väldigt kreativt.
Så då hittade jag ett nytt jobb.
Och det var första steget, eller andra steget till förändring skulle jag säga.
Och sen blev det relationen, alltså min ex-man.
Och det var nog det jobbigaste i hela den här krisen faktiskt.
Men det var ett bra beslut.
Det var jobbigt för oss båda och även för vår son men vi är överens om att det var ett väldigt bra beslut på att gå framåt.
Jag fattar fan, det är ju en tung situation.
Man är ju så sammanflätad, då man har gjort så mycket tillsammans.
Så klart, det är en enorm grej.
Och passar man på att göra alla andra grejer samtidigt så är det ju helt enormt.
Men du startade ju den här kursen i hur man började driva bolag eller hur man tog tag i det där.
Hur satte du själv igång?
Du driver ju bolaget idag, MVH, som är bekväma kontorskläder kan jag säga så.
Ja, bekväma kostymer för tjejer.
Jag brukar göra benchmark-testet när jag ska intervjua folk.
Då brukar jag säga till min flickvän att jag ska intervjua.
Om hon känner igen namnet, då vet jag att det är någon som hörs och syns.
För hon har ju ingen koppling till e-handel eller någon...
Alltså hon jobbar som lärare.
Men hon visste vilka MVH var och hon gick in och kollade och sa de där byxorna hade jag kunnat tänka mig att köpa.
Så att du...
Så jäkla kul och glad jag blev.
Du är färsad.
Så kul.
Hur drog det igång när du startade det här företaget?
Finns det verkligen inte bekväma kontorskläder?
Var detta en nisch som behövdes i världen?
Verkligen.
Jag var en misströnt kund egentligen.
Jag försökte hitta en kostym som var bekväm.
Jag skulle resa.
Min första affärsresa i Brasilien skulle jag åka.
Jag var så glad över det.
Jag tänkte att jag ville ha en kostym som är bekväm, som är snygg, som är lätthanterlig, som inte väger hur mycket som helst.
Jag försökte hitta det på marknaden.
Jag var lite överallt.
Både på nätet och i fysisk handel hittade jag ingenting.
Jag köpte tre kostymar, lite billigare.
Nej, det funkade inte.
Samtidigt, under min kris och under den här perioden, ville min son inte gå till skolan.
Han skulle börja förskoleklass.
Boronlogistiken var ett stort problem.
Jag försökte hitta kläder som behövde ha på mig kostym på jobbet.
Men det var svårt att få ihop logistiken med att cykla och lämna jalle på skolan.
Han ville spela fotboll och basket på vägen dit.
Då hade jag på mig träningskläder till skolan.
Jag sprang hem och på mig en osjön kostym som cyklade till jobbet.
Jag kom till jobbet, var jättesvettig, osjön.
Kostymen var skrynklig.
Du vet.
Jag kände att vad är det egentligen?
Det ultimata, formella kostymen egentligen.
För det här är så outdated.
Kan vi snälla hitta på något annat?
Vad helst skulle det inte finnas en sån formal att man måste ha på sig kostym?
Det hade ju varit det bästa.
För då hade jag gått omkring i träningskläder såklart.
Men det var lite så det började.
Jag var liksom en väldigt trött kund och ge mig en massa...
Modeindustrin producerar x antal tusen, miljoner, plagg och ingenting passar mig.
Det är ganska frustrerande.
Som 40-åring så var jag så här, nej men jag tänker inte kompromissa med det.
Jag tänker inte på med okana kostymer, jag tänker inte på med osjöna jeans som är supertajtade, för det har jag redan gjort när jag var typ 20.
Så det var liksom lite så det började.
Jag tänkte inte nu ska jag starta ett bolag och tjäna massa pengar, utan jag tänkte att kan någon göra den här kostymen åt mig snälla?
Hur kom det igång liksom?
Var det bara så att du köpte massa resårband och satte ihop dem så blev du bekvämt liksom?
Nej, det var en dag som jag var superfrustrerad, cyklade hem och tog aldrig på mig den här kostymen eftersom jag hade lämnat i alla.
Utan jag hade på mig min tracksuit jobbat.
Jag kommer in på kontoret där alla på sig kostymer och alla bara men gud vad har du på dig?
Så började vi diskutera vad är den ultimata klädsen egentligen när man jobbar här på det här företaget.
Det måste ändå vara formella.
Jag bara men tänk om den kostymen var i det här sköna tygat.
Så då cyklade jag hem och började, jag kände mig lite tokig den dagen, men jag cyklade hem och började klippa mina träningskläder.
Jag är väldigt duktig med sax.
Jag är inte så bra på egentligen att sy och så, men med sax och med tejp och liv till lim och liksom rita det och så där, så skapade jag en första produktyr.
Och sen så berättade jag för en kompis och hon bara, det här är ju skitbra idé.
Hon tyckte att jag skulle kontakta Casal, jag bara, ja varför inte?
Det är ett norsköpingsbolag, jag kommer från norsköping.
Jag kontaktade grundaren där och frågade, är inte det här en bra idé?
Kan inte ni liksom producera en sådan här posym?
Jag kan vara projektledare.
Jag träffade honom, alltså det här var under en ganska kort period, alltså två-tre veckors period, det gick väldigt fort.
Träffade honom och han sa direkt att vi har ju bara sportkläder, men jag kan stötta dig, jag kan para ihop dig med en fabrik, med tyger, vad mera.
Starta ett eget bolag, jag bara, ja vad kul.
Det låter jätte, jag har ju alltid någonstans också velat driva eget bolag, jag har jobbat på Alm i förut och coachat andra personer att starta bolag, så det var ju liksom, det låg ju inte långt ifrån att starta det här.
Så jag gjorde det parallellt med mitt jobb, som ett litet sidoprojekt som var roligt, för att skapa mig en skön kostym.
Och var någonstans är vi i tiden nu?
Det här är 2019.
2019 och hur lång tid tog det innan, innan liksom första riktiga klädesplagget var hemma liksom.
Inte en prototyp utan det här, det här är en riktig, det här är ett riktigt plagg liksom.
Jag kan sälja det här.
2019, ska vi se här, prototypen kom i mars innan corona.
Ja men på hösten, 2020, så hade vi produkter klara.
Men vi la ingen större år utan vi väntade till 2021 för det var liksom många, många förskjutningar med corona och allting som hände.
Så augustus 2021 fick vi vår första leverans och det var liksom en provtryckning.
Vi köpte in ganska lite för att se kommer vi sälja någonting.
Men hade du ändrat mindset då för du sa att i början så var det mer att det här är ett problem, jag ville titta lite grann på det och se om jag kunde göra.
Du när du gjorde första batchen här, hade du då börjat tänka att det här ska jag bygga till ett bolag eller var det fortfarande bara vi ser vad som händer här?
När jag startade bolaget och sen när jag fick kontakt med MQ som var intresserad av att köpa in kläder där, så tänkte jag att det här är min grej.
Så när jag är ganska fort så tänkte jag att nej jag vill driva det här bolaget.
Men rent ekonomiskt så behöver vi vänta lite.
Timingen var inte liksom rätt.
Plötsligt tog lite längre tid än vad jag tänkte med att hitta rätt fabrik och ta fram de här prototyperna så att de såg väldigt bra ut.
Men det var nog bra tid.
Så det gick ganska fort från att jag ville att någon annan skulle göra det till att jag skulle driva eget.
Du fick in MQ redan från starten, vilket ju är lite märkligt.
Hur gick det till?
Typ veckan efter att jag träffade Casale, typ december 2019, så kontaktade jag MQ på LinkedIn.
Då hade de bytt inköpare, en tjej som var från Norrköping, och jag skickade tre slides.
Jag gillar hur alla i Norrköping bara, get together.
Jag vet.
Det var som ett flow verkligen.
Det var rätt kontakter och rätt timing.
Hon tyckte att min presentation var jättebra och det gick i linje med vad de sålde.
Då träffades vi i januari året efter.
De var intresserade av att se prototyper och eventuellt göra ett inköp.
Sen tackade de ju nej så att de gick ut med en konkurs själva.
Då 2020.
Men det gjorde ju såklart att jag tänkte gud vad bra.
Jag har inte en produkt klar men de vill faktiskt köpa in den här produkten.
Så det var klart att det gjorde att jag tänkte klart jag ska satsa.
Men kom inte de tillbaka?
Blev inte de market eller nåt sånt?
Var det en annan inköpare då?
Nej, det var samma.
Precis, det var samma.
De tackade nej då och sen kom ju de tillbaka starkare.
Och jag kontaktade dem 2021 i början av året.
Och frågade om jag kunde bara få hyra en del utav deras yta.
För att vi ville gärna ha både online och fysisk handel.
Och jag tänkte att många kunde kanske vilja prova kläderna, känna och klämma.
Det är viktigt.
Och när jag pratade med dem då så...
Då var det en ny person på marknad och försäljning.
För det var en helt annan person jag skulle prata med.
Och hon var äldre och låger och tyckte att nu ska vi prata om inköp istället.
Så då rullade ju bollen igen.
Så det var ju egentligen tack vare att jag...
Ja men...
Jag får skryta lite nu.
Men tack vare för att jag liksom vågar ändå fråga dem igen.
Kan vi åtminstone få en liten pop-up-yta?
Så visar de intressen.
Men det hände ganska mycket ganska fort där.
För du tog väl också in lite investerare och liknande ganska tidigt i bolaget.
Det tog ganska lång tid i och för sig.
Vi började...
Vår första pitch var...
Man själv har en syn på det och vi utifrån har en syn på det.
Ja men absolut.
Nej men det tog ett och ett halvt år ungefär att få in kapital.
Och varför vi gjorde det och varför jag gjorde det, det var ju för att jag hade ju inte själv kapital.
Och tyvärr så är i modebranschen man vinder väldigt mycket kapital när man köper in produkter dessvärre.
Det är ju liksom utmaningen.
Jag hade ju en rådgivare på Almea också under hela nattidan och de tyckte väl att vi skulle börja pitcha.
Så det gjorde vi där första gången maj 2021.
När du säger vi, finns det vi eller är det du?
Ja det finns vi.
Malin Källström blev ju delägare efter ett och ett halvt år ungefär och Michelle Malm.
Malin träffade jag på Kassal.
Hon jobbade med teknisk design, som är väldigt duktig på design-bitar.
Hon hjälpte till med prototyperna.
Jag träffade henne på Kassal och hon skulle sluta och bara ta ett år paus och resa.
Men så kom corona så det blev svårt att resa.
Så då blev hon fast med mig istället.
Hon gällde till vid sidan av.
Hon tyckte också att det var en rolig projekt.
Även om hon inte förstod utmaningen, för hon var van vid att ta på sig träningskläder på jobbet.
Så hon har varit med sen start.
Och Michelle, där skrev jag också ett inlägg på LinkedIn och letade efter de som kunde e-handel.
För jag visste inte hur man gjorde.
Hon skulle precis börja plugga som e-handelsmanager på EON.
Så ja, vi var tre, definitivt.
Vi 2021, 2022 där så.
Både att lansera första kollektionen, få in kapital.
Det var en jätterolig resa, verkligen.
Tufft.
Och hur gick själva pitchresan till där?
Vad fick ni inför investerare?
Hur var det att pitcha någonting så tidigt i en uppstart, eller om man ska säga innan det är ett fullt etablerat bolag?
Snacka om att det var olika pitch.
Då, 2021 i maj, när jag knappt hade, vi hade inte ens sålt den enda produkten, så det är svårt att ha hård fakta då.
Det var bara min vision och vad vi hade tänkt, och vad vi trodde framåt.
Så det var mycket svårare att pitcha än när vi väl hade börjat sälja.
Då kunde man ju visa svart på vitt, att det fanns kunder som var intresserade.
Nej men den resan var väldigt intressant, den var tuff också, den var liksom, det blir ju också lite känslomässigt i början, för man är inte van, eller jag var inte van, och det var väldigt, man berättade om sin egen lilla bebis typ, det här har jag gjort, jag vill ju investera, fast det fanns ju inget konkret då i början.
Så det var väldigt svårt då.
Men sen, tiderna har gått så himla fort, så det är svårt att komma ihåg alla tider och hållpunkter.
Men vi fick in den första investeraren som heter Pelle Gustafsson, som grundade Outnorth.
För det var väldigt många som sa nej, men när han tackade jag så började fler tacka jag som.
Vi fick in tre investerare till att börja med, och det här var på hösten år 2021.
Men då fanns det ändå en tanke kring att vi behöver få in mer kapital för att vi ska kunna stänga den här rundan.
Så vi fortsatte pitcha till olika nätverk, olika ängelinvesterare, mest digitalt faktiskt, men också fysiskt.
Sen var vi också med i den här tävlingen, vad heter den, Bling Startup.
Just det, nej jag vet vilken du menar.
Ja den var vi med i.
Och där gjorde vi också skillnad, där fick vi in kanske ett en miljon faktiskt.
Och gjorde ju såklart att vi fick mer medial utrymme också, och fick lättare att få in ännu mer deläggare.
Vad är det som har gjort?
Du fick ju dels hjälp här direkt av han, Kassal snubben där, och sen så kom du in på MQ tidigt, även om det sen blev en konkurs för MQ, och sen uppstart igen.
Och så fick du in dina kolleger där via någon LinkedIn-post, och någon som hoppade in som någon intern först, jag har kommit på vad heter det på svenska.
Och sen Outnorth, det är ju ändå ett riktigt bolag, om du förstår vad jag menar, det är ju ändå cred att få in på det sättet.
Vad är det de tycker om med dig eller med bolaget?
Har du reflekterat över vad det är som säljer?
Alltså jag tror att många har tänkt tanken kring sköna kostymer.
Det är det ena.
Sen det andra är väl passionen och övertygelsen som jag hade och har kring bolaget och våran produkt.
Det handlar ju inte bara om att skapa den här produkten, utan också ha en hållbarhetstank kring den när man skapar produkten.
Så det är liksom en kombination tror jag.
Och man vill väldigt gärna se en förändring i modebranschen.
Det kan jag säga att alla våra delägare känner att man vill förändra någonting och vi tar det med en produkt som är väldigt, väldigt bra.
Men är det fortfarande så att är ni fortfarande ganska ensamma med sköna, bekväma kostymer eller har det kommit mycket kopier?
Eller hur ser Mark9 ut nu?
Det har inte kommit många kopier men det finns absolut fler som gör det vi gör.
Jag vill inte gå in på vilka varumärken.
Om det finns ett billigare varumärke som har lite copy-pastat våran copy och försökt göra det vi har gjort.
Men jag skulle säga att kvalitetsmässigt, vi har 50 % återkommande kunder.
Vår utmaning är att vi är nya kunder fortfarande, men när vi väl får in en kund så älskar de våra produkter och det är för att de håller väldigt länge och är fantastiskt sköna.
Men man ser absolut att det kommer mer och mer varumärken som tänker på det här sättet.
Men vi har verkligen nischat oss verkligen och vill göra produkter som inte finns på marknaden.
Det gäller även det här att det finns storlekar 32-48.
Vi vill gärna att alla kvinnor oavsett form ska kunna ha på sig en kostym.
Där har jag kanske inte sett att det finns så många som gör.
Det är de storlekarna som vi faktiskt ställer mest utav, 44, 46, 48.
Vi har funderat på att det kanske går upp i så olika mera, men det är ju en lönsamhetsgrej också, vilket kan vara svårt ibland.
Är det du som designar kläderna eller vem är det som...?
Det är jag som designar, ja precis.
Hur är det att kombinera designjobbet med att driva bolag?
Ibland kan det ju lite stå i motrelation och framförallt ta det ju tid från varandra.
Hur styrde du det?
Alltså vi har ju allt, tänk att vi gör allt.
Vi designar, vi administrerar, säljer, marknadsplan, vi har ju alla roller i bolaget.
Alltså, det som kan vara jobbigt är ju att både jag och Malin vill designa väldigt många designs, och att vi är väldigt kreativa som personer.
Så vi får ju stoppa oss själva från att skapa nya produkter.
Och det är såklart livet i tråkigt.
Man behöver både både design, inköp och controller.
Hells skulle man bara vilja gå hejvilt och bara designa massa olika kavajer och byxor och t-shirt och klänningar och skjolar.
Och vi hade en ganska brett sortiment från början, men vi har ju också insett att vi behöver vara mycket mer smalare i vad vi erbjuder faktiskt.
Rent lönsamhetsmässigt nu när vi är små.
Vem är det som drar gränsen?
Hur stor är er ryggsäck av produkter som ni vill släppa någon gång de närmsta fem åren om ni hade kunnat?
Oj, alltså vi är ju, det är alldeles så många.
Det är runt 50 produkter minst.
Om jag och Malin sätter oss en dag så har vi en hel kollektion designad.
När vi pratar kollektion så kanske vi pratar om 10-15 produkter, inte 150.
Det är väl det som vi också försöker tänka på.
Vi vet inte hur många säsonger det finns i modebranschen nu.
Jag vet inte hur många kollektioner som släpps.
Det är det som är en större drivkraft hos oss faktiskt, att inte göra det för att vi vill inte ta för mycket resurser från naturen.
För det är det vi gör egentligen, alla som driver bolag, alla som skapar en produkt.
Det vi gör, även dina gymverktyg, du tar ju en metall, du tar resurser från jorden och skapar en produkt.
Och det gör vi helt fritt fram.
Det finns ju inga regler för vem som får göra det.
Vill vi skapa en värld som är lite bättre om några år, så behöver vi kanske fundera på vilka produkter verkligen som behövs på marknaden.
Och inte bara tänka på vad vill jag göra som designer, eller vad vill jag göra som entreprenör.
Så det är väl den delen som också håller oss lite lugnare i hur vi lanserar produkten och hur vi vill tänka.
Jag går in och kikar, jag kan inte låta bli, och tittar när du pratar så, hur menar du att det påverkar vad ni tar fram för produkt?
Har du något exempel på hur det styr liksom vad man tar fram?
Ja men vi försöker hitta så, våra design är väldigt klassiska och väldigt sådär basic.
Det ska vara en kunskår, och man ska kunna ha det under lång, lång tid.
Sen har vi levt väldigt mycket med färg istället, för själva passform och själva designen på hur en byxeljacka ser ut.
Så det är väl det.
För det kommer ju trender hela tiden, det kommer ju nyheter hela tiden inom moderbranschen som man skulle kunna anamma och kunna designa mer utav.
Ni försöker göra så klassiska plank som möjligt, som du kan ha oavsett vad det är för trender.
Jag vet att i början så, för du är väl gammal basket-spelare, var det inte något sådant?
Ja, exakt.
I början så flörtade ni ganska mycket med sportvärlden.
Jag har sett några sådana gamla bilder och lite sådana där reklam.
Är ni fortfarande åt det eller har ni gått mer mot mode nu?
Eller var står det?
För du nämnde ju kasal där till exempel i början, men ni är ju inte en konkurrent i kasal, utan vilka är det som kikar på era kläder?
Vilka är era kunder?
Vem är det som bara, fan det här, varför har inte haft detta liksom?
Ja men när jag målade på start så ville vi att det skulle ha lite sportig känsla.
Det var ju de kunderna som hittats först i oss är ju de som kanske kommer från idrotten eller de idrotta mycket eller jobbar inom hälsa med mera.
Men sen är det ju väldigt många kunder som är mitt i karriären egentligen som jobbar som jurist eller inom bank eller inom staten och har kombinationen barn med karriär.
Men grejen är att våra kunder är ju mer, jag tror att de själva har upplevt det här problemet, att de behöver ha på sig kostym men vill vara bekväma.
Och det finns inte, så det är väl där skulle jag säga som kärnan ligger.
Men sporten definitivt, det är ju fortfarande.
Om vi hittar på våra hemsidor så finns det ju ett foto på mig med en basketball.
Samtidigt så vill vi ju att våra kunder ska förstå att det är inte bara för de sportiga sportnödarna, utan det är även för en vanlig kvinna som inte gillar sport, men som har mycket att göra under dagen, som kanske cyklar till jobbet eller reser, eller bara ska leka med sina barn.
Är det en vanlig invändning hos kunder, eller anledningen till att de inte handlar?
Är det för att de tror att det kommer se ut lite som tränningskläder i verkligheten?
Eller hur gör man för oss?
Det här är bekvämt men det ser snyggt ut på riktigt.
Förstår du vad det är jag menar?
Jag tror att vi är ett premiumbrand och har de priserna vi har, är en första hindret att göra en investerarekning.
Sen undrar många kunder vad är egentligen skillnaden mot ett annat varumärke som är jättekänd, som Filippa K eller ett annat varumärke som man känner till, som man vet om.
Man vet vilken storlek man ska köpa, man vet vad man får med mera.
Det är väl den största inlandningen.
Och det första liksom när man investerar, för det finns många kunder som återkommer till oss och säger att nu har jag haft koll på er i två år, och nu har jag äntligen investerat i de här byxorna, och nu fattar jag vad ni menar.
Bara yes.
Så ja, det...
Det är i och för sig en ganska skön komplimang att de liksom sparar ihop för att kunna gå in och köpa kläderna.
Har ni butiker och liknande?
Finns ni på market och liknande idag?
Inte längre, men vi finns på Leensit i Stockholm.
Vi har en liten butik där, på tio kvadratnätter.
Jag tänker att detta är sådana kläder som man gärna vill testa lite i längre.
Verkligen, och när det är ett nytt varumärke så vill man gärna prova sig framkring modeller och storlek.
För det är väl det som är det svåraste att få på rätt när man köper online också, såklart.
Men ni har inga egna planer på att starta butiker här framöver?
Nej, inte just nu.
Vi vill bara hitta andra butiker som kan vara bra ambassadörer för oss, där man kan ha olika events med mera.
Men inga egna butiker just nu.
Kan vi inte diskutera lite hur er strategi ser ut där?
För ni jobbar via egen e-handel.
Syns ni på andra e-handlar eller jobbar ni via andra återförsäljare?
Eller hur ser modellen ut?
Vi kommer försöka jobba väldigt mycket med vår egna hemsida.
Vi har tittat lite på Zalando och lite andra återförsäljare, men i det här läget när vi bara är två personer som jobbar med bolaget, så försöker vi prioritera och fokusera mer på våra egna e-handlar, och att söka mer fysiska butiker som kan jobba med oss för att träffa de här första gångskunderna och övertyga dem över hur sköna våra kostymer är.
Så att det är i och för sig, det är egentligen en hemlighet men vi kommer lansera på LensOnline också ganska snart.
Men vi jobbar ganska restriktivt och ganska fokuserat för att vi vill kunna erbjuda kunderna så bra priser som möjligt egentligen.
Är det en hemlighet eller är det inte en hemlighet?
En jävligt dålig hemlighet.
Ja men faktiskt.
Det är bara, ärligt talat så kommer jag på det nu.
Det har varit så himla mycket de här veckorna som har varit så jag glömde vart att vi ska lansera det ganska snart faktiskt.
Vad är det som har varit, då kan du låta detta vara kvar Kristoffer.
Ja, det tycker jag.
Vad är det som har varit så mycket de senaste veckorna?
Det känns överlag som att du har haft ganska intensivt senaste år kanske.
Ja, men det har det.
Det har varit intensivt.
Vad är det som är så intensivt?
Det som har varit nu är ju att vi har lanserat en ny design på vår hemsida.
Och att då göra om allting med alla länkar, alla produkter och allting.
Det har tagit väldigt mycket tid.
Men vi ville gärna investera och fokusera på att se till att vår e-handel var lite, lite bättre än vad det var innan.
Eller mycket bättre skulle jag säga.
Så det har tagit väldigt mycket tid.
Och sen är det ju intensivt för att vi gör ju allting i bolaget.
Det är verkligen så.
Och sen är jag mamma också.
Så att det här att hitta tid för sig själv och att ha lite roligt också och vara med vänner och familj, det är faktiskt svårt att få till ibland.
Jag köper det.
Hur, vi pratade ju här innan om lite påsk och så där.
Jag har ju två små pojkar och du har en son och två bonuspojkar här.
Men lite mer åt tonårshållet.
Så jag har grovångest till den dagen när de problemen dyker upp.
Men det är ett tag kvar som tur är.
Hur ska man säga, nu, jag hade väl kanske inte löst uppstarten med familj, om jag ska vara helt ärlig.
Utan då jobbade jag ju liksom non stop.
Och så hade jag ju ingenting annat att fokusera på.
Hur gör man, för det är ganska vanligt när man sitter i den här sortens dialoger, att ofta är det någon som antingen startade bolaget för länge sedan, och då är det ofta innan familj eller liknande, eller så kanske de gjorde det under, när man var mamaleder eller pappaleder, men då har man ofta med sig partnern på något sätt i den satsningen, det är också ganska vanligt.
Men det här att starta upp bolag mitt i en skilsmässa, och en ny partner och ett nytt liv, och man bryter, vad har gått bra där och vad har gått dåligt där?
Har du nåt smart grej att dela värde av?
Stor fråga kanske.
Jättestor fråga.
Jag hade inget alternativ, det var ju så min situation och mitt liv såg ut.
Jag ville göra det här och det kändes som att det var min passion, så jag hade inget val riktigt.
Sen tror jag man får fokusera och prioritera.
Jag har fått jobba väldigt mycket med att prioritera min tid på bästa sätt.
Det är jättesvårt, det är en utmaning.
Det handlar också om att se till att man ska ha energi till saker och ting också.
Inte bara tiden, men också energi.
Man ska inte bara sitta av tiden.
Nej exakt.
Det är klart att det har varit svårt.
Att jag har fått göra saker ibland som jag har känt att nu borde jag varit med min son istället, eller med min familj.
Men å andra sidan så är alla, hela familjen, även mina föräldrar och mina syskon, de är väldigt involverade i det här bolaget och vet om och stöttar mig på alla sätt och hejar på mig.
Men nej, det har varit tufft såklart.
Upp och ner, men jag vet inte.
Om jag hade varit ensam, ung och...
Då hade det kanske gått fortare, kanske.
Men jag vet inte.
Men jag kanske inte hade haft den kunskapen som jag har nu, så att, ja.
Jag tänker att man inte behöver lägga upp hinder för sig bara för att jag har barn.
Så att säga då till sig själva att nej, men det går ju inte nu, för nu är det för sent.
Det är så många tänker att när man ska få barn så kommer man inte kunna resa och man kan inte kunna göra ditt eller vattnet.
Nej, fast du kan ta med, som min son fick vara med på en Dolphinsbachs nu, vi hade en liten typ fashion show.
Då var han med och hjälpte till och han tycker det är jättekul.
Men visst, det är ju lite jobbigt men också jätteroligt.
En combo liksom.
Jag har ju köpt det, jag har haft med ungarna med på serviceuppdrag och sånt ibland, när vi servar löpand.
De är ju enormt i vägen men det är ju vad det är liksom.
Men det jag tänkte säga var att en av de fördelarna som jag hade när jag startade upp var ju att det var ju, det var ju bara jag, alltså det kan ju vara en nackdel men det var ju bara jag som var ägare i bolaget, vilket gjorde att jag kände ingen press utifrån att göra någonting.
Du hade ju en del delägare här och även kollegor som kanske hade gått in med en viss, så här, ja men nu tänkte jag att vi skulle göra det här.
Hur hanterar du den yttre pressen?
För det ändå, ja det tänker jag är en ganska tuff, som man inte snackar så mycket om.
Ja men det är det tuffaste.
Man vill inte misslyckas, man har ju ett ansvar gentemot alla de här människorna, självklart.
Hur är jag hanterad?
Ja men, jag tror...
Kan du hantera det?
Ja precis, exakt.
Kan jag hantera det?
Nej men det är jättetufft ibland, absolut Joel, det är det.
Och hade jag liksom haft kapitalet från början så hade jag kanske inte behövt ta in lika mycket.
Å andra sidan så har ju de hjälpt mig med sin kompetens också.
Men det är klart, det är en press, definitivt.
Och det är någonting man får prata med andra om och diskutera och prata med sin styrelse.
Jag har en styrelse som är väldigt bra, som jag kan liksom lyfta mina tankar och mina känslar.
Så att, det är väl det jag har sagt flera gånger tror jag till mig själv också att när man driver bolag så behöver man ju också utveckla sig själv.
Man behöver göra saker som är väldigt jobbiga och som är pressande.
Men ofta så kan jag ju hantera det.
Jag lär mig någonting av det.
Ibland så säger jag bara till mig själv att vad är det värsta som kan hända?
Jag är en människa, jag driver ett klädbolag.
Vad kan hända?
Typ så.
Och då blir det lite lättare faktiskt.
Du nämnde här att du har en styrelse och du har också tidigare nämnt i någon intervju här att du hade han kasalsnubben lite som en mentor, eller dörröppnare och så där.
Vad är din syn på att hitta bra folk som ger input?
Jag kan tycka att det är ganska svårt att hitta människor som genuint bryr sig.
Alltså, man kan ju bry sig lite grann, men att verkligen så här, någon ska ta sig tid och bry sig om ens liv.
Ja, hur hittar man sådana människor?
Alltså jag har ju haft tur då för att jag har väldigt många som har hjälpt mig utan att könt mig.
Du kanske är lite mer likable än vad jag är.
Kan du ha det?
Kanske, nej.
Alltså, det är intressant ändå för att jag är en väldigt självständig person.
Jag gör gärna saker själv.
Och hade jag kunnat ekonomiskt, jag antar att du kunde det, därför startar du själv, då hade jag kanske gjort det.
Men samtidigt så vet jag inte om det hade varit så bra för mig.
För då hade jag kanske isolerat mig själv lite mer.
För jag är nog en sådan person som gärna liksom fokuserar, isolerar mig och kör på.
På det här sättet har det ju blivit att jag får vara med i gemenskap med andra människor som har väldigt mycket kontakt, nätverk, det hade inte jag själv.
Där jag kan lära mig väldigt mycket.
Men utmaningen såklart blir ju att man kan inte lyssna på alla råd man får, utan man måste ju ändå gå med sin magkänsla och sin egna kunskap också ibland.
Det kan vara svårt ibland att navigera kring alla råd och liksom, för vi har en väldigt engagerad ägegrupp och styrelse.
Hur ser närmsta åren ut här?
Ni har ju vuxit ganska stadigt får man väl säga, men ni har också vuxit med lite minusresultat.
Hur går tankarna kring det framöver och hur ser visionen ut här den här nämsta åren?
Vi behöver komma upp i omsattning.
Vi behöver synas med, vi behöver liksom, att fler än din fickvän ska veta vilka vi är.
Det är verkligen, det är liksom det första målet nu, det är att hitta liksom breakeven-kulturen.
Vi har den och vi styr mot den, men det är jättetufft, det är det, eftersom vi inte producerar i volym.
Vi har ju höjt priserna nyligen ytterligare för att bli mer lönsamma, men det är jättetufft just nu.
Det är inte lätt.
Men visionen är att vara ett lönsamt bolag som fortfarande producerar i Europa och gör kvalitativa produkter, produkter som gummen har verkligen investerat i.
Den kommer aldrig att försvinna, för det är klart att det är lätt att segla mot Kina och Asien, där produktionskostnaderna skulle halveras i princip.
Men det är ingenting vi vill göra här och nu.
Och tittar man på marknaden nu och vad som händer runt om globalt, så tror jag att man behöver sitta i sin båt och vara lugn.
Jag tror verkligen att fler och fler kunder kommer tänka till i vad man investerar i för produkter.
För det ser man nu, att vi lever i viss del till en demokrati, vi kan rösta.
Men alla pengar du investerar i produkter gör ju att företag får makt.
Det ser vi ju på Google, på Facebook, på U-Name, de har värsta maktan.
Vart vill jag, hur investerar jag mina pengar?
För jag och alla kunder har sina pengar.
Jag tror verkligen att, och det ser vi, det är många kunder som boykottar amerikanska varor just nu.
Det är jättetråkigt att vi inte någon gång kan få ett flow.
Vi har varit med om så otroligt mycket hittills och jag vet inte.
Vi har ju startat upp i en riktig period.
Det har bara varit motvind ska jag säga.
Så jag ser fram emot merbindan snart.
Jag vet att du har sagt att ni gick globalt direkt.
Finns det en nackdel där i att, när du säger att fler människor ska höra talas om oss, så blir det ganska svårt att bli välkänd på en stor marknad reklammässigt jämfört med att ta en marknad i taget.
Sen kanske den svenska kundgruppen inte är enorm, men vissa marknader...
Jag håller med.
Ja, jag håller med.
I början tänkte vi att vi öppnar upp för globalt, ser vad som händer.
Men sen har vi ju svingt ner sakta men säkert och verkligen fokuserat på Skandinavien just nu.
Nederländerna seglar lite åt Tyskland men det är ju en väldigt stor marknad.
Så vi fokuserar väldigt mycket mer nu.
Men vi hade ändå en sån här open mind i början.
Men ja, att vara på olika marknader kräver ju väldigt mycket för alla har ju olika...
Det är juridik, det är logistik, det är accounting, det blir väldigt mycket mer jobb, så är det ju.
Så ett fokus är där vi är nu i alla fall.
Vilket är lite tråkigt.
Det är som att designa få produkter.
Man vill ju hellre designa fler produkter.
Jag förstår, du hade passat med 900 miljoner in till i bolaget och så började du bara kunna köra på ni där passioner ligger.
Jag tänkte säga, vad är det som har funkat för er i att synas?
För mordvärlden är ju bizarr på det sättet att det finns väl ingen marknad som är så belammrad med folk som vill lyckas.
Det är ju typ omöjligt att nå igenom.
Vad är det som har nått igenom?
Finns det någonting som ni märker att det här har funkat för oss?
Det som har funkat för oss var Jessica Almenäs som var ambassadör för oss från början.
Hennes bild där hon spelar basket i en grön kostym.
Rent specifikt har vi fått så många kommentarer på att det är just den som gjorde att man förstod vad det var för produkt och vill investera.
Men jag tror kombinationen att vi hade både onlineförsäljning och fysiska butiker på papps och hade en välkänd ambassadör som gjorde att vi ändå slog igenom 2021 i augusti när vi lanserade.
Det var nog den kombinationen tror jag.
Plus att det nyss hade varit corona och människor hade suttit i träningskläder framför datorn och nu inte ville gå tillbaka till jobbet i en okonkostym.
Det är väl en kombination av saker och ting.
Kan ni inte få, jag kollar inte på det programmet så är jag inte helt hundrad, men mästarnas mästare, där gör de väl lite utmaningar.
Kan ni inte få alla damer i den serien att köra er kostym istället för träningskläder när de gör sina utmaningar.
Det hade ju varit fackligt.
Det hade varit grymt.
Men vet ni att Nilla Fischer hade på sig en brokostym under de här avsnittan?
Jaha, vad roligt.
Hon körde inga utmaningar med den.
Men hon satt vid middagsbordet med den.
Så det var trevligt ändå.
Ja, kul.
Det är kul när man får lite kändisnamn.
Det är ändå lite löjligt egentligen.
Men det är jättekul, ja men såklart.
Även för detta jämställdhetsminister Paulina Brandberg har ju haft våra Harmony Jackets.
Så det var väldigt roligt att se.
Det är klart man blir glad.
Kan du ge mig några, du har en ganska bred företagsresa här på bara några år.
Ni har ju gått igenom både covid och lokonjunktur och tagit fram produkter och nylanserat hemsida och tagit in kapital och hela den här.
Men finns det några generella lärdomar där som du känner att här lärde jag mig mest, eller det här var knepigt på riktigt, här önskar jag att jag hade fått höra det här.
Finns det något?
Det finns ju väldigt många.
Men jag måste fundera lite.
Jag ska också säga till alla som lyssnar att till till Marias cred här så har hon inte läst frågorna i förväg som det kan ni ta till er, det är hon och Fedja Borovits som inte har läst frågorna i förväg så all cred till er som faktiskt bara tar det såsom det kommer.
Gud vilken stor fråga Joel, det är ju så mycket, det jag hade velat lära mig mer av och vilja veta är ju alltså hur jobbigt det är och stressigt det är.
Hade du velat veta det på riktigt?
Ja det ville jag, jag ville veta.
De sa så här att vet du att det kommer vara tufft för ditt team, det kommer vara tufft för alla liksom, rent psykiskt.
Gör de här mentala ökningarna och bli starkare mentalt.
Ja, det hade jag faktiskt velat.
Okej, det är inte liksom en skill eller en viss grej, utan det är snarare att hantera det mentala spelet, eller är det det som har varit det tuffaste?
Det är nog nummer ett.
Nummer två hade nog varit att våga satsa lite mer pengar från start på foton och online, alltså e-handeln.
För vi har hela tiden tänkt budget, budget, budget, budget.
Men sen har vi hela tiden behövt ta steg att förbättra hela tiden.
Och jag tror att om man vågar, och det är svårt att våga kanske bara när man inte vet att det faktiskt håller hela farsedén, men om jag fick göra om någonting, då skulle jag ju bara ha satsat pengarna på det direkt.
Och kanske hitta en logga och ett varumärke som som man kan skydda globalt direkt.
För det har också varit ett problem för oss.
Jag kan inte gå in mer på det, men det har varit jättetufft faktiskt.
Och tagit mycket tid och energi.
De två sakerna hade jag gjort annorlunda.
Jag gillar det, jag gillar båda där.
För jag tror att det är ganska vanligt att man, som du säger till exempel med foton, det är lätt att man så här, vi tar en, nu till exempel inom Geometry, vi tar en AI-genererad bild och säger det så där.
Det blev en 3D-skratch.
Absolut, men det är värt att åka ut och montera den för du ska sälja den i tre år sedan.
Och då är det lika bra att ha det från start.
För att det är bättre försäljning, kunderna ser, du får mindre frågor, det, du vet.
Men det är en tuff kostnad eller tidsgrej att ta i början.
Samma sak med produkttexter och info.
Alla de här vanliga, tråkiga grejerna liksom.
Och jag gillar också den andra punkten där med att hantera det mentalt.
Jag kan själv minnas, det var någon gång någon hackergrej, de tog alla våra texter och la upp på porrssajter till exempel, så det blev ju vd-värdigt.
Och jag kommer ihåg paniken jag hade, men andra gången det händes var det såhär, ja ja, det är inte jag som ska hantera det, det är ju IT som hanterar det, jag kan lika gärna fokusera på inköp så länge, för jag kan inte göra något här och då.
Och då stänger man av hjärnan från det och spenderar ingen energi på det.
Man blir lite sur första gången med det liksom.
Ja ja, så är livet.
Men det är ju den här att kunna stänga av hjärnan från vad som bara är.
Fan, man kan inte ta detta nu ändå, jag tar det imorgon liksom.
Jag tror någonstans har jag tänkt att om jag är igång, och om jag är på huggat, då kommer det gå bättre.
Och det kan ju stämma till viss del, att man behöver liksom ha momentum och vara snabb på bollen.
Men man kanske kan kombinera det med att chilla lite också, och bara våga liksom lita på att det går bra.
Du har byggt upp någonting, det kommer att gå bra.
Och det finns andra som kan hjälpa dig att lösa problem, precis som du säger.
Så den kombinationen.
Så det har varit tufft för mig att inse, för jag har ju varit på bollen hela tiden, nu kör vi, nu ska vi ändra det här, nu ska vi...
Och det var också hackade faktiskt för två år sedan.
Och det var det värsta jag varit med om.
Jag fattar den paniken du hade, jag hade också det i flera månader.
Det var verkligen...
Jag kunde liksom...
Hacka-attacken var under en vecka, och de försökte hacka sig också i inga mejl.
Så kände man liksom såhär privat påhoppad verkligen.
Men sen kunde inte jag lugna ner mig hela hösten.
Jag kände att det var någon som var ute efter mig under liksom flera månader.
Det var jättetufft tycker jag.
Så jag förstår, precis.
Ja det kommer väl bara bli mer.
Det är ju en massa sådana hybridkrigsföring.
Det är bara att slappna av med det.
Det är bara att slappna av.
Maria, stort tack för att du var med i podden.
Och sitter ni och lyssnar på detta på väg till jobbet och känner fan vilka obekväma byxor jag har på mig nu så kan ni gå in på MVH och kika.
Då finns det ett alternativ till att leva sitt liv i misär.
Stort tack Maria.
Ha det gott.
Tack så mycket.
Tack.
Jag har haft ungarna med på serviceuppdrag ibland när vi servar löpand.
De är ju enormt ivägade, men det är ju vad det är.